[Music]
all right today's question comes from
debbie in oklahoma debbie writes my
husband and i are a blended family his
kids live with their mother and it's
been a long difficult road with them
they both dropped out of college and one
is currently not speaking to us the
other has voluntarily limited her work
hours so she's still struggling
financially and doesn't get benefits
years ago we set a number in our budget
for them since i received child support
for my son that i used exclusively for
him
well i'm not against
helping them from time to time i feel
like we've passed the time where we need
to be regularly budgeting money for
grown-ups who don't live with us
especially if they are not in our lives
at all what are your thoughts on this
yeah i'd cut this off today
completely agree totally we're done you
know
done yeah
number one i don't give money to people
who don't speak to me i mean just kiss
my butt that's ridiculous
uh that does not buy you anything it
does not cause anything good to happen
it's it's just a sign of complete
enabling yeah um dad's guilt over
former guilt money over whatever
happened that caused the divorce is he's
still playing disney dad and they're 27.
yep and that's just bs it's hurting them
well it is the whole situation there
everybody's just allowed them to
continue they're stunted back when the
divorce happened and they're still
living emotionally at about that age
and uh because no one especially
their mother
his ex is pushing any buttons and
so yeah i mean i would just say listen i
love you if you're hungry
come over you can have dinner
anytime just holler at us ahead of time
if we got something on the stove we'll
share it with you we'll never let you be
hungry and you know but we're not we're
not giving able-bodied adults money go
get a job what do you think about this
dave i i i don't like the idea of i
don't have adult kids yet i don't like
the idea of
giving
money to adult kids just as a part of a
budget no if adult kid currently says
hey i'm going to go to college i'm going
to go to med school
you know maybe for tuition or for but
just
no your adult kids do not need to be
online it's like it's an allowance yeah
it's just ridiculous
that's the definition of adult yeah
you're on your own
puppy
so i mean you know it's uh
old old hard school dad you know
you're 18 years old uh you're either in
college or you get a job and you leave
that's right i mean one of the two and
by the way if you're in college you
probably gotta leave so um
so you're gonna leave that's hardcore i
mean but it's there's there's something
developmentally
we we have i've read several articles
and you probably know a thousand times
more about this than i do about the
we've got a group of people
that not all of them not the entire
generation but two too large a
percentage of a generation who their
emotional
evolution their emotional growth was
stunted
by living in mom's basement
and i actually think it goes one
generation before that we have a group
of adults who are using
kids to prop themselves up and they've
created this right like
i need my kid that's where i get my
validation i didn't get it from my
marriage i didn't get it from work i
didn't get it from society i got it from
my kid and here you are you blink and
you look up and they're 25 years old and
you're still sending them an allowance
yeah because there is pain as a parent
when they leave yeah
because you're no longer
you're it's part of your identity that's
it when your kids become your identity
when their success becomes validation
yeah but but i mean it's it's healthy
that
i'm a dad of us these are my children
that's right and then when they're
still your children but they're quote
grown children
yeah yeah when their their performance
on the t-ball field becomes your
valentine's day well that's always been
a problem yeah but i'm talking about
that
there's a natural tearing
that the parent
also experiences when the kid moves out
and becomes an adult yeah there's like
oh god and you've experienced how much
easier would it be if i could just throw
500 bucks and they'd stay another month
yeah maybe another month and then you
know what i mean
and uh but yeah
it's it's it's giving a drunk a drink
ultimately although they're not drinking
they're just emotionally immature right
they have not evolved and now they don't
know how to receive they're 27 years old
and they're operating on about a 17 year
old emotional level is that right you've
seen that data oh gosh well it's just
tough to take feedback from a boss who
says i want this report done differently
or the first time you have a
fight with the person you're dating it's
all over and it's you know i mean
there's no there's none of that
emotional resilience yeah
and a maturity yeah so yeah that's what
happens here so yeah you need to cut
them off it'll be good for them is what
we're saying yes
um now yeah you know but now
uh let me take let me change that to a
second because i made a mistake i said
you need to cut them off your husband
needs to cut his kids off you don't need
to say a stinking word right because
you'll be the wicked witch of the west
my father married this woman and after
that they never helped us anymore no
that
that's you may get the blame whether you
do it or not but you need to stay way
back from this and push him out into the
light he needs to be a grown-up push him
out onto the stage and he stumbles out
there and makes the speech
yeah that's and you just stand back in
the wings and give him a thumbs up